this leads very naturally to another key
feature of stoic physics that would be
very influential for later developments
too which is the idea of cosmic sympathy
or sympathia this is basically the
notion that all things in the universe
are interconnected and interdependent on
each other a speck of dust on some
planet in a far away solar system has a
direct connection with my thumb or with
you or with the trees outside everything
is connected in an almost occult
esoteric way because after all
everything thing is one thing don't get
me wrong this interconnectedness is also
somehow physical to the stoics just as
God or the pneuma is material even
though later figures such as the
neoplatonist would interpret these ideas
of sympathia in more metaphysical ways
to the stoics reality is an
interconnected web where all things are
connected to everything else which also
allows them to explain ult things like
divination and esoteric reading